You thought sneezing and itchy eyes were bad?
Yeah, try having your skin feel like its on
fire every time you take a shower.
Hey everyone, Laci Green here for DNews.
I have terrible allergies, so about this time
of year I kind of start feeling sorry for
myself.
But you know what?
That ends today my friends.
I have seen allergy hell, and it ain't pretty.
Here are 5 real allergies people actually
have to put up with:
Number 1?
WATER.
I mean, you'd think that since our bodies
are MOSTLY WATER that might be a little problem.
But, as it turns out, people with a water
allergy are alive and functioning - it's estimated
that 1 in every 23 MILLION people has it.
The allergy is called Aquagenic Urticaria,
and it causes itchy hives when the person
comes into contact with water.
The hives can last for hours.
A woman from Britain has to drink diet coke
to survive and another from Australia can
hardly stand to shower for 1 minute before
it starts burning!
Poor thing!
I'll never take a shower for granted again.
Well, I probably will like a week from now.
Number 2: EXERCISE.
It's the allergy we've all been hoping for.
Nah, I'm just kidding.
It actually sounds awful.
Exercise Induced Anaphylaxis can be lethal.
It starts with hives and skin irritation,
then trouble breathing.
If it is severe enough, anaphylaxis will cause
your blood pressure to drop and your lungs
tighten until you can't breathe.
Scientists think that this rare condition
may be brought on by eating something they're
allergic to and then working out right after.
Number 3: THE COLD!
I mean, I think I'm psychologically allergic
to the cold but there are some people who
form rashes and have trouble breathing when
they step out into the cold, find themselves
in cold water, or even drinking cold beverages.
"Cold Urticaria" is an inflammatory disorder
that can cause a flood of histamine to be
released in the body, leading to a drop in
blood pressure, fainting, and even death.
So much death.
I guess I'll stop complaining about the cold
now.
Number 4 is SEMEN.
Semen allergies are definitely a thing, it's
thought to affect anywhere between 20-40,000
Americans.
People with this allergy can experience vaginal
burning, swelling, itching, hives, and shortness
of breath after coming into contact with their
partner's semen.
Strangely, there have also been a few cases
of men being allergic to THEIR OWN semen!
Doctors say the best way to treat this allergy
is to avoid contact all together -- but I
dunno, that seems like it would be kind of
hard if it's coming out of your own body.
Last up is the sun!
This is the most depressing thing I've heard
all day.
It's apparently not even that uncommon for
someone to develop a rash, bumps, crusting,
or blisters when they're exposed to sunlight.
It takes the idea of a sunburn to a whole
new terrifying level.
Thanks for joining me for DNews everyone,
do you have any allergies?
Tell me about it down below and don't forget
to download the new TestTube app!
Tweet us that you downloaded to @DNews and
we'll be giving 1 winner a full DVD set of
the brilliant Life on Earth series.
Bye bye!